again from a football standpoint look we
absolutely know what the rules are and
we are 100% in compliance the depth of
my knowledge of every single rule that
we're responsible for but another part
of the organization does or doesn't do
as part of their whether it's game
presentation or TV shows or stuff like I
mean I have no idea what that is
oh the old to the best of my knowledge
plausible deniability from Bill
Belichick the Patriots coach and that's
all relevant now because what happened
yesterday the bengals disclosed that
there was some sort of an incident on
sunday at their game against the Browns
where there were credentialed members of
the patriots organization where they
were employees or independent
contractors it really doesn't matter
they were there they were filming a
feature for a part of their ongoing do
your job online video series of a day in
the life of an advanced scout so cameras
were there to film the scout but
reportedly allegedly whatever there was
some filming being done with one of the
cameras of the Bengals sideline during
the game which brings us back to
everything that we learned and probably
have forgotten about Spygate from 2007
thou shalt not film the opposing team
sidelines for the purposes of getting
signals that then can be used to match
up the signals with what they did and
you crack the code and you're not
allowed to do it and the Patriots paid
the punishment for 12 years ago and now
guys they are back down that path
they've admitted that it happened they
claim that it was inadvertent basically
the example that I gave last hour and
two hours before that they got caught
with their hand in the cookie jar and
their argument is we didn't know our
hand was in the cookie jar nothing
nothing was done intentionally or
deliberately I think it all comes down
to what actually was on that camera that
taped that video that was confiscated by
the league I assume we'll find out at
some point but Peter your first reaction
when you heard about what shall be known
is Spygate - my first reaction is that I
hope the league acts quickly with this
whatever the whatever the deal is
because you know the the the worst thing
I think not only and look I don't care
about any individual
teams in this so I don't care about the
Patriots but clearly there's going to be
at least half of the football society
inside the game outside the game who are
gonna think hey if it's the Patriots
it's there they're guilty and that is
the one thing that bothers me about this
thing get this thing adjudicated quickly
so that we find out what the truth is I
don't think we know the total truth
right now we need to know the total
truth it sounds on the surface like this
is something that a very aggressive team
in in-house sort of PR spin on its team
the way the Patriots are they do a lot
with their TV shows they do a lot with
their online footprint right so my
feeling is there's a good chance that
this is just one part of the building
having no idea that you can't go out and
film from a team sidelines or film
toward a team sidelines especially in
the press box
it seems incredibly obvious and stupid
that some team says hey we're gonna
cheat so let's set it up right in the
press box where everybody can see us
right shooting this right so that's at
the end of the day yeah right at the end
of the day I'm sure I'm sure the league
is going to do whatever the league
should do I would just say in the
immortal words of Paul Tagliabue you
know what he said about things like this
is all's well that ends forget about it
ending well just end this nip it in the
bud don't take weeks to investigate it
take 48 hours let's be done with this
whatever it is yeah agreed
I mean they do I don't think there's
anything there again you know to what
Peter said how do you know if we don't
know what solutions okay you want to
come to the conclusion that they're
exonerated without knowing what's on
tonight get it can I state my case big
mouth shut up okay so yeah I just think
yeah I don't think there's anything
there I don't think there's anything
there because you don't a dental crew
with Patriot stuff on not like anybody
would be watching them yeah Bill
Belichick is gonna send that crew to hey
go in the press box where everybody's
gonna know you're working for New
England and have credentials on from the
Cleveland Browns it's a New England and
film the other teams sideline guys will
get away with it and the second thing
you know you are done the second thing
is Bill Belichick oculus say some rent I
know I've already admitted did it happen
we interpret my press box a cheat that's
probably filmed the field from the press
but we get that they're doing a show
series so they're shooting the field you
know again Mike if that comes out and
this shows that it's totally they were
filming the sidelines and we're zooming
in on a guy giving signals then you
could sit here and call me stupid but if
not I'm gonna call you tomorrow okay and
that your stoop they're not Bill
Belichick he's gonna trust some random
video crew that he doesn't know hey guys
film the sidelines for me okay and bring
it back in the tape okay bill Bell
checks Chris that's not if it happens if
there is any type of malicious intent
here and we won't know until we actually
see the tape and I think once we see
like you said if they're zooming in on
guys giving signals then it's not some
accidental inadvertent thing and I don't
know their where we're gonna see the
tape maybe Jay Glazer will get it maybe
you won't but it's not Bill Belichick
issuing these mandates from on high
right the the boss doesn't know what the
underlings are doing all he knows is he
wants as much information as he can get
about the opponent and this is a way to
get in he's gone insane Bill Belichick
who know been the first time because he
was telling them to do it they didn't
care it wasn't in the rules of the NFL
so they were getting information Mike
Bill Belichick knows everything that's
going on in that building like
everything literally it doesn't because
that has nothing to do with the football
side it's a TV production and now we're
just throwing it on New England and I
just I I don't agree with it that's all
I think Peter Peter you see what you got
yourself into today
he's just sitting back like being in the
middle and having
bottom line is what's on the tape is
really going to control where this goes
from here
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports